Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a Mandscape.
Más en un momento.
Terremoto político.
Queridos amigos, amigas, así es cómo podemos
describir el enorme vuelco político que se
ha producido en Colombia.
Un país que acaba enfrentado a unas de las
elecciones más importantes de toda su historía.
Antes de las primera vuelta todas las encuestas
señalaban que por primera vez, un proyecto
claramante de izquierdas, muy de izquierdas,
podía convertirse en la opción favorita
de los colombianos.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Eso es exactamente lo que pasó.
El centro-derecha y en general la clase política
tradicional del país fueron borrados del
mapa.
El exalcalde de Medellín, Federico Gutierrez,
Fico, el candidato de centro-derecha que aglutinó
los apoyos de fuerzas como el Partido de la
U, el Partido Conservador, el Partido Liberal,
Cambio Radical o el Centro Democrático ni
siquiera pasó a segunda vuelta.
Contar con el respaldo de pesos pesados de
la política colombiana de la talla de Cesar
Gaviria, Andrés Pastrana o, incluso, el mismísimo
Álvaro Uribe - por no hablar del propio presidente
Ivan Duque - no le valió absolutamente de
nada.
Los colombianos dijeron a los políticos de
siempre.
De esta forma, Gustavo Petro, el azote de
la derecha y uno de los iconos de la actual
izquierda latinoamericana ganó la primera
vuelta.
Claro que quizás lo hizo de una forma muy
diferente a lo que se esperaba.
Que Rodolfo Hernández, un candidato independiente
le diera el zarpazo a Federico Gutierrez,
Fico, es algo que puede convertirse en su
peor pesadilla.
C1("Este es realmente el escenario más difícil
imaginable para Petro y no creo que su equipo
de campaña esté muy contento.
Será una lucha cuesta arriba para él en
la segunda ronda" Sandra Botero, analista
política de la Universidad de Rosario en
Bogotá.)
Ahora a Petro se le han complicado y mucho
las matemáticas.
Rodolfo Hernádez acapara buena parte del
voto antiestablishment que el mismo Petro
persigue.
Y no solo eso, en conjunto, los candidatos
que no pasaron a segunda vuelta sumaron más
de 6 millones de votos.
Ahora la mayoría apoyan a Rodolfo Hernadez
contra Petro.
Para colmo el candidato de izquierda ya no
puede enarbolar el discurso del cambio, porque
si el auténtico outsider de la política
colombiana no es él, sino su contrincante.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué explica semejante vuelco
electoral en Colombia?
¿Por qué el centro-derecha y el uribismo
han recibido semejante castigo?
Y quizás la pregunta de todas: ¿Qué va
a pasar con Colombia?
Atentos.
Pero antes….
EL FIN DE UNA ERA)
Durante las últimas décadas Colombia ha
sido un rara avis en la política latinoamericana.
Digamos que hablamos de un país que habitualmente
ha ido por libre y ha sido inmune a las modas
de la región.
(Por ejemplo, mientras que durante los años
60 y 70, Latinoamerica se llenaba de dictaduras
militares de derecha, Colombia se mantuvo
como una democracia tan estable como restringida
en la que dos partidos, el liberal y el conservador
se alternaban el poder.
Luego, durante finales de los 90 y comienzos
de la década del 2000, al tiempo que la región
comenzó a girar hacía la izquierda dando
lugar a lo que se conoció como el socialismo
del siglo XXI, la política colombiana empezó
a inclinarse hacia el lado contrario, hasta
el punto de terminar en el año 2002 dándole
el poder a Álvaro Uribe, un candidato fuerte
del centro-derecha que de una forma u otra
ha dominado la política colombiana hasta
hoy.
Mientras que en el resto de América Latina
se han producido alternancias muy abruptas,
Colombia fue, otra vez, la excepción.)
Y lo cierto es que aparentemente las cosas
han ido relativamente bien.
En términos reales, entre 1999 y 2019 el
PIB per cápita creció a un ritmo del 2,4%
anual.
No es para tirar cohetes, pero por ejemplo,
para que os hagáis una idea, supone el doble
de lo que creció Estados Unidos durante el
mismo periodo de tiempo, 2,5 veces más que
el crecimiento de España y unas 4 veces el
crecimiento de países como México o Argentina.
Colombia prácticamente igualó el desempeño
de Chile durante las últimas 2 décadas.
Por supuesto esto vino acompañado de importantes
cambios sociales.
La violencia se desplomó, el número de jóvenes
cursando estudios terciarios se cuadriplicó
y prácticamente todos los indicadores sociales
mejoraron con fuerza.
Incluso la recuperación del coronavirus ha
sido una de las más rápidas de toda América
Latina.
En 2021 la economía ya había sobrepasado
su nivel prepandemia y, por ejemplo, la producción
industrial postpandemia era un 7% superior
a la de 2019.
Y no se trata sólo de la economía.
A nivel exterior Colombia también ha cobrado
peso.
El país se ha incorporado a la OCDE, hace
5 años se convirtió en el primer país de
América Latina en obtener el estatus de “socio
global” de la OTAN y en abril del 2022 el
Presidente Joe Biden designó a Colombia como
"aliado principal fuera de la OTAN", un estatus
que conlleva un trato preferente en materia
de seguridad y defensa.
Pero, amigos, amigas, hasta ahora.
Las últimas elecciones han sido un golpe
en la mesa, un punto de inflexión que lo
ha cambiado todo.
Colombia ha dicho basta a los partidos tradicionales,
al centro-derecha, al Uribismo y a todo lo
que tenga que ver con ellos.
Y la pregunta qué podemos hacernos es, ¿por
qué?
¿Qué demonios ha provocado este enorme cambio
si los datos aparentemente no son nada malos?
Pues bien, la respuesta la podemos encontrar
en lo que ha sido la presidencia de Ivan Duque.
Atentos.
2(UN PRESIDENTE MALDITO)
Ivan Duque se presentó a las elecciones con
grandes promesas de cambio, transformación
y modernización de la economía y la sociedad
colombiana.
Sin embargo, lo cierto es que casi podríamos
decir que su mandato ha estado maldito.
Durante estos 4 años Colombia ha sufrido
una pandemia, un huracán de fuerza 5, las
mayores revueltas sociales en 70 años, una
crisis migratoria sin precedentes y hasta
una crisis internacional de la energía y
los productos alimentarios.
Más difícil imposible.
Evidentemente escapar de esta era una misión
muy pero que muy complicada, así que el nivel
de aprobación del presidente Duque ha llegado
a las elecciones con un paupérrimo 28%, al
tiempo que el 85% de los colombianos consideran
que el país está en la dirección equivocada.
Claro que el Presidente tampoco empezó con
buen pie.
Por él y porque la oposición no le dio tregua.
En 2019 las manifestaciones y las protestas
inundaron las calles del país denunciando
las intenciones del Presidente de privatizar
empresas públicas, reducir el salario mínimo
para los jóvenes o reformar el sistema de
pensiones para dar peso a la parte privada.
La falta de respuesta, negociación y liderazgo
del presidente terminó congelando cualquier
programa de cambio.
(En 2020 las protestas volvieron contra la
brutalidad policial y luego en 2021, el gobierno
de Duque presentó sin mucha pedagogía ni
mucho consenso una reforma fiscal para elevar
el impuesto sobre la renta a las clases medias
y el IVA sobre los bienes básicos y poder
así reducir los impuestos sobre la actividad
productiva.
La reforma podía tener sentido pero las cosas
se hicieron tan mal que volvió a incendiar
las calles.)
Y al final, el propio Duque terminó haciendo
básicamente lo contrario: aprobar otra reforma
fiscal que básicamente subía los impuestos
a las empresas del 31 al 35%.
Exactamente lo contrario de lo que defendió
durante años.
Así que, al final, cambios en el modelo económico
más bien ninguno.
Luego otro terreno resbaladizo fue la violencia
y la seguridad, otra de las grandes promesas
de Duque las cosas tampoco le pudieron salir
peor.
Evidentemente Colombia no ha regresado a los
niveles de violencia de finales de los 90
y principios del nuevo siglo, pero las cosas
no han ido por buen camino.
C2("El país está en una situación absolutamente
dramática debido a los problemas de seguridad
que existen, tanto en lo que tiene que ver
con el conflicto armado como en lo que tiene
que ver con la seguridad en las ciudades"
Camilo Prieto, profesor asociado del Departamento
de Relaciones Internacionales de la Pontificia
Universidad Javeriana de Bogotá)
Durante el mandato de Duque la violencia se
ha recrudecido por la creciente actividad
de bandas de narcotráfico, disidentes de
las FARC y el ELN.
Para que os hagáis una idea, tan sólo entre
2019 y 2022, 835 líderes sociales y vecinales
fueron asesinados por todo el país.
Al tiempo que las acciones de combate de grupos
armados se volvieron a disparar.
Fijaos.
Y si a todo ello le sumamos los efectos de
la pandemia nos podemos hacer una idea de
porqué Duque ha terminado con un nivel de
aprobación tan bajo.
Claro que no todo es culpa suya ni mucho menos.
Qué los colombianos hayan dado un golpe en
la mesa tiene también mucho que ver con esto.
Atentos.
3(SUEÑOS ROTOS)
Queridos amigos, amigas, el puñetazo en la
mesa que han pegado los colombianos no tiene
que ver con la típica crisis a la que este
país nos tiene acostumbrado.
No tiene que ver con las guerrillas, el crimen
organizado, los narcóticos o la pobreza en
el mundo rural.
No.
En este caso el descontento procede sobre
todo de los jóvenes y las zonas urbanas que
sienten una enorme frustración por los sueños
rotos.
Por supuesto, la pandemia ha jugado un papel
clave en este sentimiento.
Porque,sí, la economía colombiana se ha
recuperado y su producción es mayor que antes
de la pandemia, pero no ha ocurrido lo mismo
con el empleo, que sigue por debajo, ni tampoco
con las tasas de pobreza.
En 2021, casi el 40% de los colombianos vivían
sumidos en la pobreza y más del 12% en la
extrema pobreza.
Y si tenemos en cuenta que Colombia tiene
más de 50 millones de habitantes, hablamos
de muchos millones de personas en una situación
desesperada.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en términos
reales, cerca de 20 millones de colombianos
sobreviven con menos de 89 dólares al mes.
Una enorme cantidad de personas que están
experimentando un enorme daño por culpa de
la inflación.
Por culpa de la energía y la crisis alimentaria
internacional los precios están subiendo
más rápido que en ningún otro momento de
los últimos 20 años.
Para colmo, Colombia es tras Perú el país
con más incidencia del trabajo informal:
algo más de 6 de cada 10 trabajadores no
tienen un empleo formal, con todo lo que ello
conlleva.
Todo esto ha sido, por así decirlo, la gota
que ha colmado el vaso y que ha erosionado
las esperanzas de cientos de miles, millones
de jóvenes.
Pero sobre todo la enorme frustración que
vive el país tiene que ver con este gráfico:
Prestad atención porque aquí está una de
las grandes claves del cambio electoral.
Durante las últimas décadas Colombia ha
hecho muchos avances, pero el ascensor social
simple y llanamente no funciona.
Ni en el campo, dónde el 80% de las tierras
agrícolas siguen en manos del 1% de los propietarios,
ni tampoco en gran medida en las ciudades.
En Colombia, si naces pobre lo más probable
es que seas pobre, y que lo sean también
tus hijos, tus nietos y hasta tus tataranietos.
Y está acreditado que la falta de evolución
es uno de los mayores combustibles para el
enfado y el descontento social.
Por así decirlo, durante los últimos años
el globo de un supuesto sueño colombiano
ha saltado por los aires.
Es el sueño roto que ha llevado a los colombianos
a decir basta.
Porque cuándo sientes que no tienes nada
que perder el voto por la revolución, el
cambio drástico o, simplemente, contra la
élite se ve como una opción mucho más razonable.
Pero dicho esto la pregunta es, ¿y ahora
qué?
Atentos.
4(LA NUEVA COLOMBIA)
Petro se las veía muy felices.
Conocido como “Aureliano” y “Andrés”
durante su paso por el M-19 este antiguo guerrillero
reconvertido en economista sigue siendo muy
de izquierdas.
Y con todos los problemas de Colombia vio
su gran oportunidad.
Fue uno de los grandes impulsores de las protestas
que inundaron las calles colombianas durante
los últimos años y por supuesto se presentó
a las elecciones con promesas de todo tipo:
Educación superior gratuita, empleos públicos
garantizados para los desempleados, más gasto
en salud y pensiones más altas.
Todo ello al tiempo que promete poner fin
a las nuevas exploraciones de petróleo y
gas y aprobar una enorme reforma fiscal para
que toda la factura la paguen solo las rentas
más altas, especialmente las 4.000 personas
más adineradas de Colombia.
¿Y cuál es el problema?
Pues…
Básicamente que las cuentas no cuadran.
Según Petro su reforma fiscal recaudará
entre 50 y 65 billones de pesos.
Pues bien, se estima que tan solo sus principales
promesas cuestan más del doble.
Así que, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
Todo apunta a que estamos ante el típico
programa que consiste en un cheque en blanco
para ganar votos pero que luego no tiene fondos.
Y si a ello le sumamos que Petro también
quiere distanciarse de Washington, subir aranceles
y renegociar los acuerdos de libre comercio,
aunque estos hayan disparado las exportaciones
colombianas, no es extraño que el propio
Banco de la República haya empezado a detectar
fugas de capitales antes de las elecciones.
Sin embargo, un momento a Petro le surgió
de repente un problema.
Ahora se tiene que enfrentar a un candidato
que es mucho más outsider que él y que tras
la primera vuelta puede haberse convertido
en el gran favorito.
Hablamos de Rodolfo Hernández, un empresario
que se ha presentado como independiente y
que ha concentrado sus mensajes contra la
casta política.
El exalcalde de Bucaramanga, al que algunos
conocen como el Trump colombiano, parece defender
el libre mercado y la propiedad al tiempo
que habla de acabar con las injusticias sociales.
Y sobre todo con los privilegios de los políticos.
Por ejemplo, ha prometido renunciar al sueldo
del presidente, acabar con la mayoría de
los coches oficiales, reducir el número de
asesores o bajar el sueldo a los congresistas.
También defiende mantener el gasto público
bajo control, buscar la forma de recortar
el IVA casi un 50% y sustituir todos los subsidios
por una especie de ingreso mínimo.
Pues bien, ahora su candidatura parece lista
para recoger los votos de la mayoría de candidatos
que no pasaron a segunda vuelta.
El propio Federico Gutierrez, Fico, ya le
ha dado su apoyo, y todo apunta a que otros
candidatos como Fajardo, John Miton y Enrique
Gómez también se identifican más con él…
A pesar de que ideológicamente es un candidato
incógnita.
Así que, quién sabe, pero está claro que
si los colombianos quieren dar un golpe en
la mesa contra la “casta política” sin
tener que recurrir a un programa muy de izquierdas
este puede ser su candidato.
Esa es al menos la esperanza del propio Rodolfo
Hernández.
Un candidato que los analistas económicos
dicen que tranquilizaría mucho a los mercados.
Sea como sea, lo que está claro es que ni
uno ni otro candidato controlan el parlamento.
Aunque desde luego Petro parece tenerlo mucho
más difícil para lograr consensos.
C4("Petro podría decir que sus políticas
son A, B y C, pero eso no significa que pueda
cumplir con ellas" [..] En el peor de los
casos, Petro presidiría un gobierno altamente
conflictivo que no haría nada en lugar de
un gobierno que desmantela las instituciones
de Colombia”.
Luis Fernando Mejía, director del grupo de
reflexión económico Fedesarrollo.)
Amigos, Colombia tiene un sistema presidencialista
y las elecciones legislativas tuvieron lugar
el 13 de marzo del 2022.
La alianza de Petró logró el mejor resultado
pero se quedó lejos de cualquier mayoría,
tanto en el Cámara de representantes como
en el Senado, dónde apenas tiene el 15 y
el 18% de los escaños respectivamente.
Así que sea cual sea finalmente el resultado,
todo apunta a que podemos esperar cierta estabilidad.
Tal y como por ejemplo ha ocurrido en México.
Donde al final Amlo ha tenido en gran medida
las manos atadas.
Lo que está claro es que Colombia necesita
poner en marcha ese ascensor social que hoy
está parado condenando a millones de colombianos.
Pero dicho esto turno para ti: ¿Qué impresión
te ha generado el resultado electoral?
¿Te parece lógico que los colombianos hayan
dado un golpe en la mesa?
¿Qué candidato te gusta más, Petro o Rodolfo
Hernández?
Si nos estás viendo desde Colombia, que sois
muchos, ¿Por quien vais a votar?
Dejadnos por aquí abajo vuestros comentarios.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvideis darle a like y suscrbiros VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.